nada primero hay que hablar de perú el
caso bien particular porque en la
competencia de florete individual
masculino el peruano uttar logró
colgarse la medalla de oro un joven de
19 años nacido en eeuu pero que tiene
mucho arraigo con perú al punto que
quiere cumplir con todo su ciclo
olímpico y estar presente en parís 2024
él precisamente venció en un cerrado
duelo al venezolano antonio leal por
otro lado también hay que destacar la
victoria de la colombiana maría de los
ángeles jaramillo precisamente frente a
una de las destacadas atletas peruanas
como lo es maría la hora de hotel por
esta razón ya colombia y perú tienen las
primeras preseas doradas venezuela y
también paraguay y chile cerraron lo que
fue este podio en ambas categorías pero
escuchemos qué fue lo que nos dijo la
atleta colombiana al concluir su
competencia
cuatro entrenamientos seguirán la
preparación francia hay un grupo de
entreno de la selección colombia que
vive en francia y paisa ya seguiremos
entrenando para prepararlos
y de esta manera entonces ya empezamos a
palpitar los juegos que comenzarán
oficialmente el día de mañana también la
esgrima estará entregando medallas esta
vez en la espada masculina y el sable
femenino arranca la competencia de
ciclismo de ruta con la prueba no tanto
en masculino como en femenino